being an entrepreneur that makes four
hundred thousand a year in Revenue
against the business that lets you take
home ninety three thousand because you
run it very profitably around something
you like HR placing Consulting against a
specific Internet of Things AR web3
people management and I think is a great
life problem is everyone now thinks you
need to make a billion dollars when you
start a business seven billion people
need to change the conversation of what
success looks like it is not to make a
billion dollars it is to actually wake
up in the morning and be in a good mood
and whether that is me who loves the
game of Entrepreneurship so much that he
goes so hard every day because he just
loves what he does or if it's somebody
who only wants to work 25 hours a week
because they all their other passions
are so interesting to them and that's
what is good for them we have to allow
for everything my biggest fear is that
you think you have to do it like me try
to figure out your version of you that
makes you as happy as my version of me
makes me